In Iraq, Islamic State militants bulldoze the ancient Assyrian city of Nimrud,...
...destroying some of the world's greatest historic and archaeological treasures.
In Turkey, the Tajik opposition leader of the Group 24 movement, Umarali Kuvatov,...
...was shot dead by an unknown assailant in Istanbul.
In Israel, a Palestine motorist rams his car into a group of pedestrians...
...close to the site of similar attacks last year.
At least five were injured.
In Brazil, Sao Paulo residents battle the worst drought in 80 years,...
...using stored water in open containers,...
...which has contributed to a dengue fever outbreak.
And finally from the Balkans, a blizzard dumped 2.5 meters of snow on Sarajevo,...
...leaving mountain communities in Bosnia cut off and without power.
One man is reported dead.